what happens to a can of pepper spray  when it's introduced to scp-914  dr greer decided to find out three  unopened cans of fox labs white  lightning brand pepper spray were  selected for testing the first can was  placed in the machinery on the setting  rough the output produced was several  piles of metal and plastic scraps  several puddles of chemicals and a  puddle of orleasin capsaicin the second  can was placed in on the setting one to  one and produced an unopened spray can  of fox labs mean green brand pepper  spray the third can was placed on the  setting very fine and the output  produced was one miniature chili pepper  when tested the pepper was found to have  a scoville heat rating of over 300  million which would make it the hottest  pepper in the world